ich bin froh und glücklich ihnen
verkünden zu können auch für diese folge
gilt 100% braig sind frei und stolz
darauf meine damen und herren
reden wir lieber über unsere eigenen
probleme da gibt es ja genug haben sie
das mitgekriegt der staat will mich
zwangs impfen und uns allen die organe
wegnehmen ja habe ich so gelesen da
stand in der neuen fit for sparen ja
wobei wir lachen wir lachen aber im
pflicht ist wahrscheinlich gar keine
schlechte idee
gerade sind ja wissen sie mehreren
deutschen schulen wieder masern
ausgebrochen und die
weltgesundheitsorganisation hat
impfgegner jetzt auf die liste der
größten globalen bedrohung gesetzt ich
habe immer wovor haben diese leute
eigentlich angst die angst davor dass
wir dazu genötigt werden etwas in
unserem körper einführen zu lassen was
ihnen wollen sehen sie und das macht die
größe dieser sendung aus dass ich jetzt
keinen sexistischen witz machen meine
damen und herren
er liegt auf elfmeter
wenn ich auch stolz drauf wirklich so
ich sag mal ehrlich sein kind nicht
impfen ist entschuldigung dumm und
asozial die herdenimmunität funktioniert
nur wenn mindestens 95 prozent mitmachen
oder wie immanuel kant sagen würde
rücksicht auf andere ist ein
kategorischer imperativ
natürlich gibt es ein winziges
restrisiko bei der masernimpfung aber
das risiko für ungeimpfte durch masern
enzephalitis zu kriegen ist 10.000 mal
höher
impfen rettet leben das ist fakt also
außer auf impfgegner demos es gibt keine
einzige wissenschaftliche studie die das
wirklich klar belegt dass impfen wirksam
und vernünftig ist aber die
kinderlähmung zum beispiel wurde
ausgerottet nach der schluckimpfung in
den sechzigern ja und wo ist ja
zusammenhang wo der zusammenhang ist die
krankheit war da um jetzt ist sie weg
das ist der zusammenhang und auch masern
auch die masern könnten längst weg sein
kann doch alles nicht wahr
ich habe eine idee ich habe eine idee
was die whu dringend auch auf die liste
der globalen bedrohung setzen müsste das
verdammte internet ja wirklich das ist
schultern an früher wissen sie hatte
jedes dorf genau einen dorfdeppen heute
sind die dorf werten des planeten
vernetzt und tauschen sich den ganztag
aus das ist das problem
ich fürchte nur bei einer impfpflicht
würden sich genau solche leute noch mehr
in ihrer filter blase ein igeln wo sie
dann informiert werden von vertretern
der germanischen neuen medizin wie zb
glauben dass dieses was wir angeblich
moerser nennen sozusagen ein trennungs
konflikt entsteht die auf die haut geht
und mir dann zeigt durch das blühen der
haut dass ich von meiner mutter zu für
weggekommen bin
ja trennungs konflikt bei ihm auch da
wurde das gehirn zu früh vom rest körper
getrennt
[Applaus]
kennedy
und wenn sie zu hause jetzt mal googeln
wofür die germanische neue medizin so
steht werden sie schnell feststellen
dass er so sigg heilpraktiker impfgegner
meinen ernsthaft kinder müssten
krankheiten wie masern durchmachen ist
eine bestechende logik
deswegen haben sich jetzt schon völlig
neue gruppen gebildet dazu gehören zum
beispiel die sogenannten ampel skeptiker
sie glauben nicht an rote ampeln und
sind überzeugt jeder mensch muss nicht
nur einmal im leben die masern erleiden
er muss sich auch mindestens einmal
überfahren lassen das ist gut für die
entwicklung viel zulauf haben auch die
sogenannten kabelisolierungen gegner die
glauben einfach nicht dass isolierte
stromkabel und stromschlägen schützt ist
eine glaubensfrage muss jeder selber
wissen
hinzu kommt viele deutsche haben nicht
nur angst davor dass ihnen was in den
körper eingeführt wird sondern auch dass
ihm was raus genommen wird
stichwort organe wir sprachen schon
davon ja 10.000 patienten 10.000
patienten warten bei uns auf ein
spenderorgan
im letzten jahr gab es aber nur 955
spender kleine diskrepanz deswegen
möchte jens spahn unser
gesundheitsminister die sogenannte
widerspruchslösung also wenn ich
ausdrücklich widerspricht ist spender
wie kommt das so an bei den organen
besitzern ich finde die aktuelle version
wesentlich angenehmer wesentlich besser
weil ich schon auch angst davor habe ja
quasi auf die schlachtbank geführt zu
werden was sie wahrscheinlich nicht
verstanden hat auch bei der
widerspruchslösung so in die organe erst
nach dem tod entnommen werden
nach dem hirntod
[Applaus]
das alles soll aus dem auch solche
ängste
20 von 28 eu staaten arbeiten mit der
widerspruchslösung und bei denen klappt
das deutlich besser als bei uns ich sag
mal wenn sie zum beispiel als deutscher
tourist wissen nicht viele
wenn sie als deutscher tourist nach
einem skiunfall in österreich sterben
dann heißt es quasi automatisch ich hab
mein herz in österreich verloren ja das
ist wirklich war klar der deutsche staat
zwingt mich dann mit der
widerspruchslösung über meinen tod
nachzudenken
also fragen wie wann bin ich überhaupt
tot was ist hirntot des schwierigen
frage gibt es aber einen relativ
einfachen test gucken sie sonntags mal
nur zehn sekunden diese sendung und wenn
sie dabei richtig spaß haben sind sie
wahrscheinlich hirntod also hallo kiwi
[Applaus]
internats
ging dann als
du solltest idee sicher jens spahn kehrt
da schon ein rechtsprinzip um schweigen
heißt zustimmung das gibt's bei uns
nicht aber es muss halt irgendwas
passieren in der theorie sind wir
deutsche große organspender in der
praxis leider weniger vielleicht könnte
man die menschen mit anreizen ködern
organspender kriegen weil sie nicht
payback punkte oder oder prämien von
energy drink hersteller du magst keine
organe aber andere mögen die auch werde
jetzt organspender und sicher die eine
dieser tollen prämien ein geiles
rennmotorrad
einen job fallschirm oder einmal
steinwand skifahren in den
österreichischen alpen
no risk no organ präsentiert von red
bull red bull verleiht lungenflügel
[Applaus]
man muss anreiz zu schaffen die große
diskussion über organspende und
impfpflicht drehen wir drüber mit einem
mann zwar nicht direkt medizin studiert
hat aber in weiß einfach teuflisch gut
aussieht mit olaf schubert vermutlich
schon mediziner
[Musik]
kommt auch noch
ja sagt olaf ich habe es gesagt jetzt
haben wir diese beiden modelle also
sparens widerspruchslösung oder die
zustimmungslösung bei der organspende
was bevorzugst du das ist darüber
nachdenken ist natürlich nie angenehm
man wird ja dann immer mit seinem tod
konfrontiert und wie man es dreht oder
wendet utopie ist irgendwie sexy ist er
quasi die wie ein riesiges funkloch ist
ja dann quasi für immer in brandenburg
nicht das macht den menschen angst aber
ich für mich ist es wichtig die
freiwilligkeit wenn also jemand sagt ich
möchte nicht dass man mir irgendwas
entnimmt dann müssen wir uns auch daran
halten oder wenn es doch irgendwie sein
muss dass man ihnen von also wenigstens
betäubt vorher wird er nicht merkt was
man aus nämlich die frage braucht man
alles die regelung muss natürlich vor
allem attraktiv sein für diejenigen die
uns die organe liefern
am liebsten sieht man wirklich die die
tiefschnee skifahrer nach so einer
lawine
da kommen die organe gleich gut gekühlt
und die müssen wir natürlich fair
verteilt werden und damit alle die
gleichen chancen haben bin ich nicht
dafür dass man die organe versteigert
also jetzt natürlich nicht im
krankenhaus sondern dann richtig seriös
in hamburg irgendwie auf dem fischmarkt
und 84 prozent der deutschen sind ja
theoretisch bereit organe zu spenden
nur halt nicht geeignet also
am liebsten die vom ehepartner da hat
man dann gleich zwei fliegen mit einer
niere also 84 prozent sind theoretisch
bereit praktisch tun ist nur 36 da
klaffen klüfte also 400 theorie praxis
und theorie bin ich ja auch überzeugte
vegetarier in der theorie bist du ja
auch hübsch und die realität ist ein
wirklich er und auch tritt ins gesicht
in den fall dass andere emotionale thema
die impfpflicht was sagst du zu menschen
ihre kinder nicht impfen wollen es ja es
ist komplex es geht ja wahnsinnig viel
informationsmaterial im netz man muss
für sich den mittelweg finden also bei
uns in der familie haben so gemacht wir
haben die jungs geimpft die mädchen
nicht mal gucken was passiert also ich
sage mal pickel haben sie alle wird
schon bei euch in der ddr wo du
aufgewachsen bis gab es die impfpflicht
wie lief das foto gemacht so ich weiß
nicht ob die direkt geimpft haben oder
einfach nur irgendwas gespritzt zu
forschungszwecken direkt gedruckt
ich hab ja ich meine du siehst du den
dem aus sie die nebenwirkung machen klar
wobei ich jetzt auch nicht weiß ob die
impfpflicht heute die lösung wäre das
schild wieder ressentiments hat gibt es
neue ängste und ich glaube impfen ist
vertrauen und das vertrauen darf man
nicht zu stören und deshalb bin ich
dafür dass man einfach eigentlich das
zeug ab in die cola schluckimpfung
gesorgt da stehen dann auf dem etikett
neben den zusatzstoffen nach dem start
mit mir kein mensch
die entscheidende frage ist aber ja wie
überzeuge ich jetzt so ich sag mal ein
bisschen klischeehaft die klassische öko
mutter vom prenzlauer berg doch
mitzumachen
da sind ja die härtesten die die moderne
mutti ist ja heutzutage meist allein
stehend kein kind also ich hab da so
eine idee
also man muss er glaube ich in ihrem in
ihrer in ihrem brutgebiet auflauern in
dem berliner szene lokal wird sich sie
und dann kommen dann kommen fachkräfte
aus dem amazon hat also die gute alte
klassische die spuck impfung ja ich
meine denn
argumente alleine briesen
[Applaus]
denn
argumente ich meine sind genug
gewechselt wird also die die impfgegner
sagen ja immer nur so weit wie man sie
immer bald eine tot- und die in fünf
höfe oder sagen ja nicht irgendein sie
mal auch bald eine tote
ich glaube das ist die realität ob
geimpft oder nicht wir sterben alle
die frage ist nur wer stirbt er und da
sage ich schau mal